Let's do it!
This must be a new record.
It's not even been
ten minutes.
Oh, Lana, this is going to
be the toughest season yet.
The kiss was amazing.
Truth's got his groove back.
Oh, man! That's another
Izzy rule break.
Oh, dude!
A song would have worked out
much cheaper.
This kiss is really good.
But I think Lana's gonna be
pretty mad.
You pushed him away
six seconds too late, missy.
He's a good kisser, so…
I kind of got a taste.
I think some bad things
are gonna follow
You know what I mean?
I kissed Holly.
That "five a day"
is not recommended.
Oh-oh! These two
lovebirds are flying
straight into trouble.
I'm gonna get in
so much shit for this.
Holly and Nathan.
What you did goes against
the spirit of the retreat.
Smooching through fabric?
I've got no material
for this.
There was a pair of shorts
between our lips.
This is one of the stranger
conversations we've had
on Too Hot To Handle.
I'm into it.
What did you guys
actually do?
We maybe kissed.
-Again?
-Oh, my God!
Just a kiss?
Hmm… Let's just
check up on that.
Looks like it was two kisses
to me, but who's counting?
Oh, yeah. Lana is.
Why did we trust
Nathan and Holly?
That means
your night in the suite
has cost the group a total
of 69…
thousand dollars.
Oh, my God. I'm gonna be
in so much trouble.
He was really sexy,
but three different
rule breaks
with three different people.
They just agreed to share
a bed together tonight.
Something tells me sleep
won't be on the menu.
I have been a bit naughty.
A "bit" naughty?
I'd say that's definitely
verging on "a lot" naughty.
Let's just hope Jackson
is keeping his hands warm
under the duvet.
She shoots, she scores.
I've broken Jackson tonight.
When I've got my eye
on someone,
I get them.
I might have a little trick
up my sleeve. Who knows?
What are you gonna do,
pull a rabbit out of a hat?
Oh, no.
Looks like it's
sleight of hand.
Damn, Holly!
You want fries with that?
-I hit a couple of homeruns.
-What?
Definitely got to know
the stadium.